Theresa wasn't a traitor everything she
did was a Telesis best she slipped and
fell while helping the board or
something very important
be able to do with them whatever your
tiny little heart desires as long as
they are simpler more manageable this
place is complicated enough is a days
do you really think Ford is gonna roll
over on this as long as you get that
information out of the market and frozen
potentials events it's over everything
is under control
[Music]
I want to live
not merely survive
won't give up the stream of life
smell
I got a baby
[Music]
gotta be me
what else can I be
[Music]
I'll go it alone
it was me
[Music]
right for somebody else
not right for me
[Music]
hey everybody big surprise they're
dropping a Westworld season 2 trailer
during the Superbowl this is the teaser
for that and it's basically Charlotte
Tessa Thompson's character taking
control of the operating system of the
park
while someone inside is also trying to
hack their way out like please send help
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I'll be doing videos for
Westworld season 2 just like I did for
season 1 if you remember how Game of
Thrones used to drop in April every year
it's basically taking that premiere slot
so I think they'll attach a premiere
date to that Super Bowl trailer usually
that's what they do with big reveals
like this like here you go here's some
awesome new footage but also this is
exactly when episodes are gonna start
dropping the way they're talking about
it too is kind of funny Jonathan Nolan
directed it himself and he said that the
west-world season 2 trailer will have
footage that won't appear during season
2 so he's making it sound like they're
actually gonna drop a promo for the
actual park itself as if we were people
living in the world where West's world
exists and they want to get us the
consumers to come to the park and spend
our money on them so it'd be like
Disneyland dropping an ad for Disneyland
except this is a TV show in the park is
a fictional place so it sounds like the
Della's corporation is trying to keep
things business as usual like before the
big incident during their journey in
tonight's celebration Charlotte told Lee
that he could be in charge and do
whatever he wanted to as long as the
narratives were very simple she just
wanted to keep people happy use the part
as a means to an end
like the other important part of this is
there was a plan that Teresa was in
acting as a double agent for the del O's
corporation within Ford's inner circle
we still don't know exactly what that
was but I think generally on a surface
level they just care about making more
money and there's a lot of money and
profiteering in war and things like that
so anything that you can use to make
artificial intelligence artificial life
that is 100% disposable you could use
for pretty much any function that you
could imagine so think of the Blade
Runner future of this world where
they're creating what you could call
replicants just imagine all the
different things that the delos
corporation could turn that into we know
that they would continually achieve
consciousness and then have to roll
their software back that was actually a
pretty heartbreaking reveal like every
once in a while
one of them would freak out complete the
maze so to speak and then just go
completely off the rails and they'd
either have to bag the model or they'd
just roll back the software the way they
did with Dolores assuming there's maybe
like a very brief time jump there's
still that small group of hosts that
have achieved consciousness that is now
being led by Dolores you have the man in
black that seems like he's now
interested in bringing that outcome
about as well but also with a relatively
sinister twist he still seems like he's
the villain of the series and Jimmy
Simpson who plays the young version of
the man in black also confirmed that he
was coming back for season 2 so there'll
be more flashbacks but we don't know how
those are gonna play out and if they'll
just continue that storyline in
chronological order like we'll learn
what he did directly after taking
control of the Della's corporation no
confirmation about benbarnes returning
because it would be interesting to see
if he's still alive in present-day the
old version of himself what's he doing
in other the dello sport has largely
been eviscerated who are the people that
are going to fill it because it's this
multi trillion-dollar corporation you
have to assume if they can run a park
like this you kill off the operating
board it's not like the corporation is
gonna die it's too big to die at that
point they're just gonna fill it with
other people so it'll be interesting to
see which other antagonists from the
board surface because Tessa Thompson's
character of course still alive as
confirmed by this teaser the other funny
thing about Charlotte in this teaser is
is that it's almost like the journey and
tonight program is rolling out as Ford
planned it to so everything is going to
go off the rails but Charlotte logs in
and makes a new profile for herself and
says everything is fine the narrative
was unveiled all is good it sounds like
this might be a message that's going out
publicly in a bunch of other people are
singing so she might be freaking out
behind the scenes or just not understand
that journey in tonight is actually the
process that Ford set in motion to free
all of the hosts like it's actually bad
for the corporation the journey in
tonight is continuing but Charlotte is
making it seem like she either doesn't
understand that or she's just trying to
pull the wool over the public's eyes
like everything is fine people please
keep spending your money to come visit
our Park it might be like that Simpsons
Jurassic Park parody where all the
robots at crusty land go crazy they
he has to come rescue them imagine
Krusty still wants to earn money because
his name's attached to that so after the
fact he just goes on TV and tells
everybody everything is fine please keep
buying tickets bring your families spend
your hard-earned money so that I can get
rich again but again like I said I think
the Super Bowl trailer will be a Mehta
ad for the park itself because they said
a bunch of the footage won't actually
appear during season two and that just
means that they might be using a lot of
stock footage like come visit West world
bring your family you know just like
some funny thing so we'll find out
what's going to happen in a couple days
but leave all your questions in the
comments below hopefully we'll get
confirmation on the premiere date but
like I said I think at the very latest
it'll be the third weekend in April but
I do think it'll be sometime before then
because they've already finished
shooting and all the episodes are in
post-production so while you wait for
everything click here for my
non-spoilery reaction to the Black
Panther movie and click here for brand
new Avengers infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight